It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务发展迅速。为了让花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的电话套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢再忙碌，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为每月 35 美元。这绝对是一个不会常驻的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需加收税费和政府规费。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. US population ages, many of us are thinking about how we can keep our brains healthy as we grow older. One recent study estimated that for Americans today, the risk of developing dementia at any time after age 55 is 42%. But psychologists and other researchers who study the brain have found that there are many things that all of us can do to reduce our risk, including exercising, sleeping and eating well, and staying mentally and socially engaged throughout our lives. Today we're going to talk to a neuropsychologist about the most important lifestyle factors that affect brain health
GoogleFi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不受数据流量降速影响。随着美国人口老龄化，我们许多人都在思考如何在年老时保持大脑健康。一项最新研究估计，对于当今的美国人来说，在 55 岁之后的任何时间患上痴呆症的风险为 42%。但心理学家和其他研究大脑的研究人员发现，我们所有人都可以采取很多措施来降低风险，包括锻炼、良好的睡眠和饮食，以及在整个一生中保持心理和社会的参与。今天，我们将与一位神经心理学家探讨影响大脑健康最重要的生活方式因素，
and about the practical steps anyone can take to reduce their risk of dementia. So what does a healthy brain look like as we age? What kinds of physical activity, mental activity, social involvement, and other factors are most important in maintaining brain health? What is the relationship between depression and brain health? Why are some populations and communities at greater risk of impairment as they age? And what can we do to reduce disparities in brain health? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
以及任何人都可以采取的降低痴呆症风险的实用步骤。那么，随着年龄的增长，健康的大脑是什么样的？哪些类型的体育活动、心理活动、社会参与和其他因素对保持大脑健康最重要？抑郁症与大脑健康之间有什么关系？为什么有些群体和社区随着年龄增长面临更高的受损风险？我们能做些什么来减少大脑健康方面的差异？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Veneta Dotson, a clinical neuropsychologist and professor of psychology and gerontology at Georgia State University. Her research focuses on brain health in older adults, including the links between depression and brain functioning, exercise interventions to improve brain health, and brain health disparities among older adults. She's also the founder and CEO of the company Cerebro Fit, which provides services to help people live a brain healthy lifestyle. Dr. Dotson is author of more than 100 academic articles and of the APA book Keep Your Wits About You, the Science of Brain Maintenance at. as you age. Dr. Dotson, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me. It's a pleasure to be here. Now, what does it mean to have a healthy brain? What does a healthy brain look like and how does
我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是维内塔·多森（Veneta Dotson）博士，她是一位临床神经心理学家，也是佐治亚州立大学心理学和老年学教授。她的研究重点是老年人的大脑健康，包括抑郁症与大脑功能之间的联系、改善大脑健康的运动干预措施，以及老年人之间的大脑健康差异。她还是 Cerebro Fit 公司的创始人兼首席执行官，该公司提供旨在帮助人们过上大脑健康生活方式的服务。多森博士是 100 多篇学术文章的作者，也是 APA 图书《保持清醒：衰老过程中的大脑维护科学》（Keep Your Wits About You, the Science of Brain Maintenance at as you age）的作者。多森博士，非常感谢您今天能做客节目。谢谢邀请我来。很高兴能来到这里。那么，拥有一个健康的大脑意味着什么？一个健康的大脑是什么样的，在人变老时它是如何
it function as a person ages? A healthy brain is one that continues to retain intact structure, meaning that you're not having as much volume decline as we might normally see with aging, and also one that functions well in the sense that brain cells are communicating well with each other and are able to support all the things that we do. Our movements, our thoughts, our cognitive abilities, our memory. So a healthy brain continues to do those things well. People often think of Alzheimer's disease when they think about the brain and aging. And Alzheimer's, of course, is often associated with dementia.
运作的？健康的大脑是指能够继续保持完整结构的大脑，这意味着你的体积不会像我们在衰老过程中通常看到的那样出现大幅下降，同时它也是一个功能良好的大脑，即脑细胞之间能够很好地交流，并能够支持我们所做的所有事情。我们的运动、我们的思想、我们的认知能力、我们的记忆。因此，健康的大脑会继续很好地完成这些事情。人们在想到大脑和衰老时，经常会想到阿尔茨海默病。当然，阿尔茨海默病通常与痴呆症联系在一起。
is that the main brain disorder most of us need to worry about as we get older? It's certainly the most common type of dementia. So dementia is an umbrella term for different types of conditions that cause the brain to deteriorate, affecting our cognitive abilities and our everyday functioning. And the most common cause is Alzheimer's disease. So that's certainly the one that people are worried about the most, and it's the one that we're most likely to experience. However, there are other causes of dementia, like vascular disease can cause a type of dementia.
这是我们随着年龄增长需要担心的主要大脑疾病吗？它无疑是最常见的痴呆症类型。因此，“痴呆症”是一个总称，指导致大脑退化、影响我们的认知能力和日常功能的不同类型的疾病。而最常见的原因是阿尔茨海默病。所以这无疑是人们最担心的一种，也是我们最有可能经历的一种。然而，痴呆症还有其他病因，比如血管疾病会导致某种类型的痴呆症。
Parkinson's disease in some cases can progress to dementia. So there are other age-related types of brain health conditions that we should also be trying to look out for. But the good news is that many of the behavioral interventions that help with preventing or reducing the risk for Alzheimer's disease help with those other conditions as well. In my introduction, I mentioned a few of those things that you call out in your book as important for brain maintenance, including physical activity, mental activity, social involvement, nutrition, and sleep. And I'd like to talk about these factors, starting with physical activity. Why is physical activity so important for our brains and not just the rest of our bodies? Absolutely, great question. I love talking about physical activity because it's probably the biggest activity I, I promote because you really do get the most bang for your buck when you're physically active.
帕金森病在某些情况下也会发展为痴呆症。因此，还有其他与年龄相关的脑健康状况，我们也应该尽量留意。但好消息是，许多有助于预防或降低阿尔茨海默病风险的行为干预措施，对这些其他病况同样有效。在我的开场白中，我提到了你在书中所列出的对大脑维护至关重要的几项内容，包括体育活动、心理活动、社会参与、营养和睡眠。我想谈谈这些因素，首先从体育活动开始。为什么体育活动对我们的大脑如此重要，而不仅仅是对身体的其他部分？当然，这是一个很好的问题。我喜欢谈论体育活动，因为这可能是我推广力度最大的一项活动，因为当你积极参与体育锻炼时，你确实能获得最大的回报。
If there's one thing that you chose to do with your brain, and hopefully you'll do more than one, but if you did only one, physical activity is it. Movement is truly medicine and not just for the rest of the body, as you mentioned, but for the brain. Being physically active is associated with direct changes in the structure and the function of the brain. The physical activity can literally make your brain grow in size. It can lead to the generation of new neurons or brain cells. It can help the different parts of the brain communicate in a better way and more efficiently. And so at a very basic level, the brain gets healthier.
如果你必须为你的大脑选择一件事去做——希望你会做不止一件事——但如果你只做一件事，那就是体育活动。运动确实是良药，正如你所提到的，它不仅对身体其他部位有益，对大脑更是如此。积极参与体育锻炼与大脑结构和功能的直接变化息息相关。体育活动确实可以让你的大脑体积变大。它可以促进新神经元或脑细胞的生成。它可以帮助大脑的不同部分以更好、更高效的方式进行交流。因此，在非常基础的层面，大脑变得更健康了。
The neurochemistry also changes. So it has this powerful impact on all aspects of brain health. And then since the brain itself is better in terms of the structure, the functioning, the chemistry, that then means you have a lower risk for depression and other mental health conditions. You have a lower risk for developing dementia or other age-related brain disorders. And you just also do better in life. You're able to keep your functioning longer, drive longer. That's always something that comes up with my patients who are saying,
神经化学物质也会发生改变。因此，它对大脑健康的各个方面都产生着强大的影响。此外，既然大脑本身在结构、功能和化学方面都有所改善，这就意味着你患抑郁症和其他心理健康状况的风险会降低。你患痴呆症或其他与年龄相关的脑部疾病的风险也会降低。而且你在生活中也会表现得更好。你能够更长时间地保持身体机能，更长时间地开车。这总是会出现在我的患者身上，他们会说：
don't take my keys, even though my family thinks I'm getting confused. So that functional independence that everyone wants to keep as they get older is more likely to happen if they're physically active. So I always joke that if there's a fountain of youth, it is exercise. That is exercise, physical activity in general, not just structured exercise, but movement. And we can continue to generate new brain cells even as we age? Absolutely. And there were the time when even researchers thought that wasn't true. And now we realize that actually we were wrong. We were wrong and that you can see through lots of longitudinal and clinical trial types of studies with exercise interventions, that you do see this actual growth in the brain and this generation
“别拿走我的钥匙”，尽管我的家人认为我开始糊涂了。因此，每个人在变老时都希望保持的这种功能独立性，如果他们经常进行体育锻炼，就更有可能实现。所以我总是开玩笑说，如果世上有青春之泉，那就是锻炼。那就是锻炼，通常指体育活动，不仅是结构化的锻炼，还包括运动。即使我们变老了，我们也能继续产生新的脑细胞吗？当然可以。曾几何时，甚至连研究人员都认为这是不可能的。而现在我们意识到，其实我们以前错了。我们错了，通过针对运动干预的许多纵向和临床试验研究，你会发现大脑确实在实际生长，并且正在产生
of new neurons. I'm old enough to remember being taught that you couldn't generate new brain cells. I thought, oh my God, every time I drank another beer, I was losing all these brain cells that would never come back. I'm not saying to go and have a 12-pack every day because they'll come back, But it is true that we can do things to help the brain regenerate. Now, what about mental activity? What kinds of cognitive activities keep our brains sharp? And let me ask you about many of the commercial brain training games and apps out there. Do they do anything?
新的神经元。我年纪足够大，还记得以前受到的教育是说你无法产生新的脑细胞。我想，天哪，我每喝一杯啤酒，就在失去所有这些再也回不来的脑细胞。我并不是说去每天喝一箱十二罐的啤酒，因为它们会回来，但我们的确可以通过做一些事情来帮助大脑再生，这是真的。那么心理活动呢？什么样的认知活动能让我们的大脑保持敏锐？我想问你关于市面上许多商业大脑训练游戏和应用的问题。它们真的有用吗？
There's so much to say about both of those parts of your question. So when it comes to mental activity, the key is to do something that is new and engaging and something that really challenges your brain. And so the new aspect of that is really important, meaning you don't want to just keep doing the same thing over and over again. So things like crossword puzzles and Sudoku are, again, what all my patients ask me, should I keep doing Sudoku? And I always say, have you been doing it for a while? And if they say yes, then I say, well, then do something else. Because at some point, you're not getting as much benefit from just doing the same thing.
关于你问题的这两部分，有太多话要说了。因此，说到心理活动，关键是要做一些新颖、引人入胜且真正能挑战你大脑的事情。因此，“新颖”这一方面非常重要，这意味着你不能只是日复一日地重复做同一件事。所以像填字游戏和数独这样的游戏，再次成为我所有病人都会问我的问题：“我应该继续做数独吗？”我总是问：“你已经做了一段时间了吗？”如果他们回答“是”，那么我就会说：“那去做点别的吧。”因为在某个时候，你从重复做同一件事中获得的收益已经不那么大了。
You're not getting the same challenge. But also, mix it up. I always feel like mental engagement is the fun ring healthy activity for most people. It can be going to museums. It can be going to a cultural event or a festival. It can be learning a new language, reading something novel. Anything that requires you to sort of really concentrate your attention to figure things out if you're reading a mystery novel and trying to put connections together,
你得不到同样的挑战了。但是，也要把活动混合起来。我总觉得对于大多数人来说，心理参与是一项有趣且健康的脑力活动。它可以是去博物馆。它可以是参加文化活动或节日。它可以是学习一门新语言，阅读一本新奇的书。任何需要你真正集中注意力去弄清事情真相的事情——如果你在读一本悬疑小说并试图将各种线索联系起来，
there's so much variety that you can do that engages your brain. and it allows for a lot of individuality, that each person can say, what's fun for me, but that's requiring me to do something less than passive. So passively watching TV, it's not going to be doing much for your brain. But when you're doing something that requires thinking,
你可以通过各种各样的方式让你的大脑参与其中。这允许有很大的个性化空间，每个人都可以说：什么对我有趣，但又需要我做一些不仅仅是被动的事情？因此，被动地看电视对你的大脑没有太大作用。但是，当你做一些需要思考的事情时，
problem solving, putting things together, learning something new, that covers a lot. And that's what's most important. To your second part of your question that has to do with these brain games, I don't recommend them. not because they're harmful, but because there are better ways to get the benefit.
解决问题，把事情联系起来，学习新东西，这些涵盖了很大范围。而这才是最重要的。关于你问题的第二部分，也就是关于这些大脑游戏，我不推荐它们。不是因为它们有害，而是因为有更好的方式来获得益处。
So there are some programs that if you are learning how to play a new game or learning how to use a different computer system or something like that, then sure, there's some benefit in learning something new. But those benefits can start to decline pretty quickly if you're doing the same thing. And so when patients ask me about that, I will always say, you know, your money might be better spent, you know, joining, you know, your local, art museum, getting a membership and going to their Friday evening lectures or a different adventure or something like that, that might be a better way of mixing up what you're doing
因此，有些程序，如果你正在学习如何玩一门新游戏，或者学习如何使用不同的计算机系统或类似的东西，那么当然，学习新东西是有一些好处的。但如果你一直在做同一件事，这些好处就会开始迅速下降。因此，当患者问我这个问题时，我总是会说，你知道的，把钱花在加入当地艺术博物馆、买个会员并去听他们周五晚上的讲座，或者进行其他不同的冒险上，可能会更好，这可能是调剂你所做事情的更好方法，
and not necessarily having more of the repetitive, similar sorts of games. So they're not necessarily harmful, but not necessarily the best way to engage your brain. What about social activity? What kinds of social supports matter the most for maintaining brain health? Social supports that are fulfilling is really the most important part of it. So there's no magic formula for how many people should be in your social network or what type of people should be. It could be family, it could be friends, it could be people in a community. There's a lot of variety in that as well. But the important point is that you have a network of people who you find that you can give an exchange support and that you find that fulfilling. So for one,
而不一定是非得玩那些重复的、相似的游戏。所以它们不一定有害，但不一定是让你的大脑参与进来的最佳方式。那么社交活动呢？什么样的社交支持对维持大脑健康最重要？真正最重要的是那些令人感到满足的社交支持。因此，关于你的社交网络中应该有多少人，或者应该是什么类型的人，并没有神奇的公式。它可以是家人，可以是朋友，也可以是社区里的人。这方面也有很多选择。但关键的一点是，你拥有一个由这样一群人组成的网络：你发现你可以与他们给予和交换支持，并且你觉得这令人满足。所以一方面，
person having a family system is very close-knit and that you can turn to is wonderful. For other people, that situation might be full of strife and other things that are not making it fulfilling. And so I wouldn't give necessarily the same advice to both people. So the important part is to be socially connected to the degree that you are wanting it. Some people need to have, you know, 10, 15 people that they talk to and interact with every week or every day. even. Other people are perfectly fine with one or two people that they, that they connect with. If you're filling fulfilled and you're filling connected, that's the key. If you're feeling lonely, if you're feeling disconnected, it doesn't matter how many people are around you. Then you want to
对某个人来说，拥有一个关系非常紧密且可以向其求助的家庭系统是极好的。对其他人来说，这种处境可能充满了冲突以及其他无法让人感到满足的事情。因此，我不会对这两个人给出完全相同的建议。所以，重要的是在自己想要的程度保持社交联系。有些人需要每周甚至每天都有十、十五个人与之交谈和互动。其他人则完全满足于只与一两个人建立联系。如果你感到满足，感到有联系，那就是关键。如果你感到孤独，感到与世隔绝，周围有多少人并不重要。那么你就要
work on getting that filling of connection and closeness. That's the most important piece. Let's talk for a minute about sleep. As we get older, we sleep less. We seem to need less sleep and also our sleep becomes fragmented. How damaging is that to the brain? Does it matter? Like, if I'm getting seven or eight hours of sleep, even though it's in spurts, is that good enough? So generally speaking, you want to have seven to eight hours of uninterrupted as much as possible, restful sleep. When you have sleep, it's fragmented. It's not quite as good as that continuous sleep. Part of that it has to do with the different sleep cycles that are important for different aspects of health, including brain health. But having said that, it's better to get seven or eight hours of somewhat fragmented sleep than to get five hours of straight sleep.
努力去获得那种连接感和亲密感。这是最重要的一点。我们花一分钟来谈谈睡眠。随着年龄的增长，我们的睡眠变少了。我们似乎需要更少的睡眠，而且我们的睡眠也变得支离破碎。这对大脑有多大损害？这重要吗？比如，如果我能睡七到八个小时，尽管是一段一段的，那样足够好吗？总的来说，你希望尽可能拥有七到八个小时不间断的、安稳的睡眠。当你的睡眠是碎片化的，它就不如那种连续的睡眠那么好。部分原因与对健康（包括大脑健康）各个方面都很重要的不同睡眠周期有关。话虽如此，拥有七到八小时有些碎片化的睡眠，总比只连续睡五个小时要好。
So having that time is really important. But as much as possible, trying to have that really restful and continuous sleep is important. Sometimes that's hard. Oftentimes, particularly as people get older, they might need to wake up and use. the restroom or might have other interruptions. It's not such a situation that you need to worry and then get back in bed, upset that you woke up because then you're not going to fall asleep. It's better to just get back comfortable again and get back to it and then you're still going to have a lot of benefits from having that time asleep. What about napping? Is that good or bad
因此，拥有这段时间真的很重要。但尽可能地去拥有真正安稳且连续的睡眠是很重要的。有时这很难。通常情况下，特别是随着人们年龄的增长，他们可能需要醒来上厕所，或者可能会有其他干扰。这并不是一种需要你感到担忧然后重新躺回床上、为自己醒来而生气的状况，因为那样你就无法入睡了。最好是重新调整到舒适的状态，然后继续入睡，这样你仍然能从那段睡眠时间中获得很多好处。那么小睡呢？这对你的大脑是好还是坏？
for your brain? That is a great question and one that has a complicated answer. And there's been a lot of research coming out that has changed my answer to questions like that over the last few years. So most recently, the evidence seems to point in the direction that napping can sometimes be beneficial in making up for getting less than the ideal seven to eight hours of sleep at night. So that within 24 hours or so, if you're able to get that amount of time and if napping is how you get there, that you can get some boost from them. rather than not napping. However, the important thing to keep in mind is that if someone who hasn't been napping much starts to nap a lot, not because they're choosing to try to catch up on a sleep,
这是一个很好的问题，而且答案很复杂。过去几年涌现的大量研究已经改变了我对类似问题的回答。最近，证据似乎表明，小睡有时是有益的，可以弥补夜间睡眠不足理想的七到八小时的遗憾。因此，如果在 24 小时左右的时间里，你能够获得足够的睡眠总量，并且小睡是你达到这一目标的方式，那么你可以从中得到一些提升，
but because they're feeling tired a lot, they need the nap. Sometimes that's a sign that something's wrong. So there is some indication that frequent napping, when it's a new onset, frequent napping, can sometimes be a warning sign that someone might have something going on either in terms of their physical health or even something like impending Alzheimer's disease. So watch out for suing the need to constantly not. That might be a problem. But if you're saying, hey, last night I only got five hours, I have a break in my day. I'm going to take a nap for an hour or two and you choose to do that. It's probably a good idea. What about diet? Is there any single diet that is better for the brain than others? So there is a pattern of eating that is better for the brain, but not.
总比不小睡要好。然而，需要牢记的重要一点是：如果一个平时不怎么小睡的人开始频繁小睡，不是因为他们选择去补觉，而是因为他们经常感到疲倦，他们需要小睡。有时这是一个信号，表明出了问题。因此有迹象表明，频繁的小睡，当它是新出现的情况时，有时可能是一个警告信号，表明某人的身体健康状况可能出了问题，甚至可能是即将患上阿尔茨海默病的征兆。所以要小心经常需要小睡的情况。这可能是一个问题。但如果你说，嘿，昨晚我只睡了五个小时，我白天有一段休息时间。我要小睡一两个小时，而且这是你主动选择的，这可能是一个好主意。那么饮食呢？有没有哪一种单一的饮食比其他饮食对大脑更好？所以，有一种饮食模式对大脑更好，但不是
a single diet. And I think that's really important because what I've found is that if you tell someone what we know to be true, a Mediterranean-style diet is the dietary pattern that is most associated with good brain health. If someone thinks I have to eat literally a Mediterranean diet that I need to eat what people in the Mediterranean basin are eating, that can sound restrictive. And I think it's hard when you're thinking about trying to make sure that there's brain health equity, that people from all backgrounds and cultures are able to do the things they need to for their brain, it can be discouraging if someone thinks you're going to take away their preferred foods. So instead, I always emphasize Mediterranean style diet, not Mediterranean diet, because the style
单一的饮食。我认为这非常重要，因为我发现如果你告诉别人我们所知道的真相——地中海式饮食是与良好大脑健康最密切相关的饮食模式——如果有人认为我必须字面意义上地吃地中海饮食，我需要吃地中海盆地人们吃的东西，这听起来可能会有所限制。而且我认为，当你想努力确保大脑健康公平、来自不同背景和文化的人们都能够为他们的大脑做他们需要做的事情时，如果有人认为你要剥夺他们喜欢的食物，这可能会令人沮丧。因此，我总是强调“地中海式饮食”，而不是“地中海饮食”，因为这种“式”
just means there are certain things that you emphasize and certain things that you minimize. So you emphasize more whole greens and fresh produce and lean meats. you minimize red meat, processed food, saturated fats, et cetera. And so thinking about how you can fit those different sort of keys to a healthy diet into your own preferred meals and foods and, you know, cultural traditions, allows for more flexibility for people to have a diet that best fits better brain health. So there's a lot of variety within that dietary pattern that we call the Mediterranean-style diet. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot.
仅仅意味着有些东西你要强调，有些东西你要尽量减少。所以你要强调全谷物、新鲜农产品和瘦肉。你要尽量减少红肉、加工食品、饱和脂肪等。因此，思考如何将这些健康饮食的不同关键要素融入你自己的首选膳食、食物以及文化传统中，可以为人们提供更大的灵活性，让他们拥有最适合大脑健康的饮食。因此，在我们称之为地中海式饮食的饮食模式中，存在着很大的多样性。家得宝（The Home Depot）阵亡将士纪念日促销活动让您的夏天即刻开启。
It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. Loss applies last. Price invalid May 14th from May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water.
是时候用 Nexgrill 四烧器燃气烤炉开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。只需 499 美元，即可入手 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅，尽享一整个季度的娱乐时光。今年阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受超低价格保证。售完即止。价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，特定条款适用。详情请参见 Home Depot.com 价格匹配页面。你曾说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。
We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now.
我们只是还没找到那几步路而已。我们省了多少钱？够了。够到迷路了。或者你可以预订希尔顿的房间。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。
Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get this day you expect. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for this day. We've just talked about a lot of things that we should all be doing for better brain health. And maybe that's going to be intimidating to some of our listeners. I mean, we know we should be exercising, eating healthily, getting more sleep. But that's hard to do for a lot of people. Do you have practical steps people can take to put these suggestions into practice? that's such an important question because sometimes feeling overwhelmed by the amount of suggestions can be a barrier to people making change. So I always recommend start small and start with one or two goals.
在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得您期望的住宿体验。当您想要省钱而不是惊喜时，您选择住在哪里至关重要。希尔顿，期待您的光临。我们刚刚讨论了很多为了更好的大脑健康我们都应该做的事情。也许这会让我们的听众感到畏惧。我的意思是，我们知道我们应该锻炼、健康饮食、获得更多睡眠。但这对于很多人来说很难做到。你有什么切实可行的步骤可以让人把这些建议付诸实践吗？这是一个非常重要的问题，因为有时被过多的建议弄得不知所措，会成为人们做出改变的障碍。所以我总是建议从小事做起，从一两个目标开始。
So if you hear about multiple brain healthy activities that should be incorporated into your life, you're not going to tackle all of them at one time. It's hard to start that much of a life haul and it's hard to keep that going. But if instead you say, okay, what's one or two achievable goals that I can make? I might make my first goal that I'm going to start using more olive oil and less butter in my cooking. So I'm going to do that for a few weeks. And then I'm also going to start taking 10 to 20 minute walks after dinner with my family because then I'm getting social activity and physical activity combined. That's a nice start because you're doing things that are very measurable and concrete. you have a goal, there might be sometimes where it doesn't work out.
因此，如果你听到有多种应该融入你生活的大脑健康活动，你不会一下子把它们全部解决。开始如此大规模的生活大调整很难，要坚持下去也很难。但如果你转而说，好吧，我能制定的可实现的目标是什么？我的第一个目标可能是：在烹饪时开始使用更多的橄榄油，少用黄油。所以我打算坚持几周。然后我还要开始和家人在晚饭后进行 10 到 20 分钟的散步，因为这样我把社交活动和体育活动结合起来了。这是一个很好的开始，因为你做的事情是非常可衡量且具体的。你有一个目标，有时可能行不通。
Maybe you didn't take that walk that you planned on, but you get back up the next day, plan for it again. And so starting small and having very concrete steps that are achievable helps versus saying, I heard that there's a recommendation for 150 minutes of moderate intensity exercise each week. So let me figure out how I'm going to do that every week. If you haven't been active, that's not going to happen very naturally. and it's probably not physically safe because you haven't been very active. So start small, 15 minutes, 20 minutes, see where you can fit it in. Breaking it down into manageable chunks is probably the best advice for getting started.
也许你没有按照计划去散步，但你第二天振作起来，重新制定计划。因此，从小事做起，采取非常具体且可实现的步骤，比说“我听说每周有 150 分钟中等强度运动的建议，让我算算怎么每周都完成它”要有效得多。如果你一直不活跃，这不会很自然地发生，而且在身体上可能也不安全，因为你一直不是很活跃。所以，从小事做起，15 分钟，20 分钟，看看你能把时间挤在哪里。把任务分解成易于管理的块，可能是开始的最佳建议。
One of the areas you've studied is the relationship between mood disorders such as depression and brain aging. What have you found? How are mood disorders and brain health linked? They're absolutely linked because mood disorders can, number one, mood disorders are basically based on the brain being dysfunctional, right? So the brain is the basis for mental health conditions. So mental health really is part of brain health because ultimately the brain is not operating as it should when there's a mental health disorder.
你研究的领域之一是情绪障碍（如抑郁症）与大脑老化之间的关系。你发现了什么？情绪障碍与大脑健康是如何联系在一起的？它们绝对是紧密相连的，因为情绪障碍可以——第一，情绪障碍基本上是基于大脑功能失调，对吧？所以大脑是心理健康状况的基础。因此，心理健康确实是大脑健康的一部分，因为归根结底，当出现心理健康障碍时，大脑并没有按应有的方式运作。
Having poor brain health, not being physically active, not doing the things that we just talked about, can put someone at risk for developing depression or other conditions. And at the same time, conditions like depression can cause further. damage in when it comes to brain health. So having untreated depression can start to wear away at the brain in various ways so that you have more loss in sort of the size and the health of the neurons in the brain, the brain cells, where you have dysfunctional connections between parts of the brain. Those things can also come as a consequence of having depression. So there's a bidirectional relationship between brain health and depression. And in older adults,
拥有不良的大脑健康、不进行体育锻炼、不做我们刚刚讨论过的事情，可能会使某人面临患上抑郁症或其他病症的风险。与此同时，像抑郁症这样的病症会导致大脑健康受到进一步损害。因此，未经治疗的抑郁症开始以各种方式侵蚀大脑，导致大脑大小和神经元健康（脑细胞）受损更严重，大脑各部分之间的连接功能失调。这些情况也可能作为抑郁症的结果而出现。因此，大脑健康与抑郁症之间存在着双向关系。在老年人中，
who already have some vulnerability because our brain does naturally change as we get older, then it can put an older adult at a higher risk for depressive symptoms. What's interesting about that, though, is that we've seen from lots of research studies that older adults tend to have a lower prevalence of major depression compared to younger people, but what we see is that there's a higher prevalence of what we might call sub-threshold depressive symptoms. So symptoms that don't meet criteria for major depression, but they're still clinically meaningful. They still impact their cognitive functioning. They still affect their day-to-day functioning. So they're clinically significant sub-threshold symptoms, and those tend to be more common in older
由于大脑随着年龄增长会自然发生变化，他们已经具有一定的脆弱性，这可能会使老年人面临更高的抑郁症状风险。不过，有趣的是，我们从许多研究中看到，与年轻人相比，老年人重度抑郁症的患病率往往较低，但我们看到，我们可能称之为“阈下抑郁症状”的患病率更高。也就是说，这些症状不符合重度抑郁症的标准，但它们在临床上仍然是有意义的。它们仍然会影响他们的认知功能。它们仍然会影响他们的日常功能。因此，这些是具有临床意义的阈下症状，它们在老年人中往往更为常见，
adults, potentially because you have this extra risk that comes from the brain having changed with aging. At what age is it important to start thinking about maintaining your brain? Is it ever too early, or too late to get started. It is never too early. It is never too late. Brain health is a lifelong process. So literally from the moment we're conceived and what's happening in the prenatal environment
这可能是因为你拥有来自大脑随衰老而发生变化所带来的额外风险。从什么年龄开始考虑保持大脑健康是很重要的？开始行动会不会太早，或者太晚？永远不会太早。永远不会太晚。大脑健康是一个终生的过程。所以从我们受孕的那一刻起，胎儿产前环境中所发生的事情，
through the rest of our lives, what we're exposed to what we experience impacts our brain. It affects how it develops. It develops how it is maintained in sort of young adulthood, middle life. And it affects how the brain ages over time. So there's never a time. when brain health is not relevant. There's never a time when we don't get benefits from brain
到我们余下的一生，我们所接触到的、我们所经历的，都会对我们的大脑产生影响。它影响着大脑的发育。它影响着大脑如何在成年早期、中年期得到维护。它影响着大脑随着时间推移如何老化。所以不存在大脑健康不相关的时候。不存在我们从有益大脑健康的行为中得不到好处的时候。因此，我也认为要明白：永远不会太晚。有些人可能，你知道的，一生中大部分时间都不活跃，不注重饮食，多年来睡眠不好。无论你现在能做些什么，都仍然会为你带来一些好处，而不管以前发生了什么。
healthy behavior. So I think understanding also that it's never too late, that there are some people who maybe, you know, haven't been active most of their life, didn't focus on their diet, haven't slept well for years. Whatever you can do now is going to still give you some benefits regardless of what happened before. What role to all of these lifestyle factors versus genetic susceptibility play in developing dementia? So if you have genetic risk factors, how much can lifestyle changes help you? It's incredibly important when you have genetic risk factors. And in some ways, you might say it's even more important. When you have a risk factor, then you want to do more to sort of make up for it. And studies show that not only do people with a genetic risk
与遗传易感性相比，所有这些生活方式因素在痴呆症的发展中发挥了什么作用？因此，如果你有遗传风险因素，生活方式的改变能在多大程度上帮到你？当你存在遗传风险因素时，这一点极其重要。在某些方面，你甚至可以说是更加重要。当你有一个风险因素时，你就会想要做更多的事情来作为补偿。研究表明，不仅有阿尔茨海默病等疾病遗传风险的人，
for conditions like Alzheimer's disease, not only do they benefit from bringing healthy behaviors, sometimes they benefit even more. So, for example, there have been some exercise studies that show greater improvements in cognitive functioning or in different brain health metrics in the people who have the APOE4 allel, which is the genetic, one of the genetic risk fibers for Alzheimer's disease. Sometimes those people actually benefit more from exercise than the people who don't have it. So it just shows that regardless of our genetic makeup, there are things that we can do to basically move the needle. We can't ever guarantee what's going to happen.
不仅能从有益大脑健康的行为中受益，有时他们受益甚至更多。例如，一些运动研究表明，拥有 APOE4 等位基因（这是阿尔茨海默病的基因风险因素之一）的人，其认知功能或不同大脑健康指标的改善幅度更大。有时，这些人实际上比没有该基因的人从运动中获得更多的好处。这正好说明，无论我们的基因构成如何，我们都可以通过做一些事情来扭转局面。我们永远无法保证会发生什么，
But in terms of the range of possible outcomes as we get older, we can push things more towards the positive side or more positive side by healthy behaviors regardless of our genetic backgrounds. One of your main areas of research is disparities in cognitive aging, the fact that some populations are at far higher risk of dementia than others as they age. Can you talk about those disparities in where they come from? This is really my passion right now, brain health equity, and thinking about how we can try to promote that as psychologists and for some of us as individuals who want to do what we can. It is really important to understand that social determinants that we think about when it comes to other conditions, mental health conditions, other physical conditions are also relevant for brain health, that people who have environmental and social stressors that put them at risk for vascular disease, cancer for all the things that we tend to think of can also be more susceptible to brain-based disorders. And that's including the broad range of mental health conditions, dementia, stroke, you name it. So I think it's important for us to, as psychologists, to consider that
但在随着年龄增长可能出现的结果范围内，无论我们的遗传背景如何，我们都可以通过健康的行为将事情推向更积极或更具建设性的一侧。你的主要研究领域之一是认知衰老方面的差异，即某些群体在年老时面临的痴呆症风险远高于其他人。你能谈谈这些差异以及它们是如何产生的吗？这确实是我目前的热情所在，即大脑健康公平，并思考作为心理学家以及作为希望尽自己所能的个人，我们该如何努力促进这一点。非常重要的一点是，我们要明白，当我们考虑其他情况、心理健康状况、其他身体状况时所考虑的社会决定因素，对大脑健康同样重要；那些使人们面临血管疾病、癌症以及我们倾向于考虑的所有其他疾病的环境和社会压力源的人，也更容易受到基于大脑的疾病的影响。这包括广泛的心理健康状况、痴呆症、中风，应有尽有。所以我认为，对我们心理学家来说，重要的是要考虑到这一点，
when we're thinking about how we can best help the clients and patients that we see. And I think it's also important to understand how that happens. An important piece of this puzzle is that people who are in marginalized communities, oftentimes face chronic stressors that are disproportionate to people who are in more advantage communities. And what we see is that chronic stress has a huge impact on the body. And without going into the long details, we have a chronic stress response that puts us at risk for chronic inflammation, for vascular conditions, for other physiological changes that we know increase the risk for dementia, increase the risk for depression. Lots of conditions end up being tied to these basic biological changes that can be brought about from chronic stress.
在我们思考如何最好地帮助我们所接待的客户和患者时。而且我认为理解这是如何发生的也很重要。这个拼图中的一个重要部分是，处于边缘化社区的人们往往面临着与处于更具优势社区的人们不成比例的慢性压力源。我们所看到的是，慢性压力对身体有着巨大的影响。长话短说，我们有一种慢性压力反应，使我们面临慢性炎症、血管疾病以及我们知道会增加痴呆症风险、增加抑郁症风险的其他生理变化的风险。最终，许多病况都与这些可能由慢性压力引起的潜在生物学变化息息相关。
So doing what we can to promote resilience to teach stress reduction techniques to, of course, for those of us who have that advocacy and desire in us, we want to change the societal contributions, but also knowing that while we're trying to make those bigger changes, helping each individual understand the impact of internalizing the chronic stress, internalizing discrimination, that it really can start to lead to a cascade of biological changes that put them at risk, and then finding where are those ways that we can try to intervene, and how can we reduce barriers to doing the brain healthy behaviors that we know can help to, at least to some degree counteract the risk factors that are present in their life.
因此，我们要尽我们所能去增强适应力，教授减压技巧；当然，对于我们当中具有这种倡导精神和渴望的人来说，我们要改变社会层面的影响因素，但同时也要明白，在试图做出这些更大改变的同时，要帮助每个人理解将慢性压力内化、将歧视内化的影响，它确实可以开始导致一连串的生物学变化，从而使他们面临风险；然后找到我们可以进行干预的途径，以及我们如何才能减少那些我们知道有助于——至少在某种程度上——抵消他们生活中存在的风险因素的健康大脑行为的障碍。
Are these things that say your primary care provider are supposed to do for you, or do you need a mental health provider or a combination? So honestly, if we were to try to address this, it really should be multiple levels of society that are doing things to try to promote brain health equity, reduce barriers for people who are in communities that are more at risk. So at a very basic level, you know, primary care, that's where most people, if anything, go to for health care. And it would be amazing if it became more sort of standard in primary care to ask about different social determinants that we know are important. Asking about where people live, their access to, you know, fresh produce and to, you know, full grocery stores. Asking about how walkable their neighborhoods are. So is it, are they able to do the freeing exercise? of walking outdoors, which is a big important barrier for some people. So my dream world would be that that becomes just standard set of questions that
这些是你的初级保健医生应该为你做的事情，还是你需要一个心理健康服务提供商，抑或是两者的结合？说实话，如果我们试图解决这个问题，社会上真正应该在多个层面上采取行动来促进大脑健康公平、为处于更高风险社区的人们减少障碍。因此，在一个非常基础的层面，你知道，初级保健，那是大多数人寻求医疗保健的首选地方。如果初级保健中开始更加标准地询问我们知道很重要的不同社会决定因素，那将是极好的。询问人们住在哪里，他们获得新鲜农产品和大型杂货店的途径。询问他们的社区是否适合步行。也就是说，他们是否能够进行户外散步这种免费的锻炼，对于某些人来说，这是一个重要的巨大障碍。所以我的梦想世界是，这成为初级保健询问的标准问题。
primary care asks. A lot of the things that can be helpful don't necessarily require seeing a mental health provider. For a lot of people, we're not talking about frank outright mental health disorders. It's just someone having the pro-dromal, just stress and other interference in their life that may lead to one later, but maybe not. So at that point, just empowering people with knowledge about here are things that you can do to try to take some degree of control in a world that's uncontrollable, you know, seeing what you can do to build your own internal resilience, especially building on
许多有帮助的事情并不一定需要去看心理健康服务提供商。对许多人来说，我们谈论的并不是彻底的、明显的心理健康障碍。这只是某人正处于前驱期，正经历压力以及生活中其他可能在以后导致心理问题、但也可能不会的干扰。因此，在那个点上，只要用知识赋予人们力量：这里有一些事情你可以去做，以在一个无法控制的世界里获得某种程度的控制权，你知道，看看你能做些什么来建立你自己的内在抵抗力，特别是借鉴
a lot of cultural groups that have strong family ties, religious affiliations, other sorts of social supports, and really drawing on that, and also capitalizing on those social supports for some of the other healthy behaviors. For example, I had an amazing opportunity to work with a local black church in the Atlanta area where they had a whole day that was focused on wellness. And so they had a healthy breakfast together. Then I came and gave a talk on exercise and brain health. Then they all went on like a five-mile walk together.
许多具有强烈家庭纽带、宗教信仰和其他社交支持的文化群体，并真正利用这一点，同时也要利用这些社交支持来开展其他健康行为。例如，我曾有过一个绝佳的机会，与亚特兰大地区的一个当地黑人教堂合作，他们举办了一整天专注于健康活动的活动。所以他们一起吃了健康的早餐。然后我去做了关于运动和大脑健康的演讲。接着他们一起进行了大约五英里的步行。
And then they came back and then had like a picnic. And so they were outdoors getting the benefits from being in nature, exercise. It was wonderful. It was such a great event. And so finding ways to promote those sorts of activities can really, I think, inspire and empower people to realize, okay, so there's a lot of things that are difficult, but I can make these steps to try to have a life that's going to be healthier overall, including my brain health.
然后他们回来举行了一场野餐。所以他们到户外享受了大自然带来的好处和运动。这太棒了。这是一个非常棒的活动。因此，找到促进此类活动的方法，我认为确实可以激励和赋予人们力量，让他们意识到：好吧，有很多事情很困难，但我可以采取这些步骤，努力过上整体更健康的生活，包括我的大脑健康。
Are there common myths about the brain or aging that you encounter among the patients? you see, and is there anything that you really want to dispel for the people who are listening to us today? There are lots of them. Unfortunately, we know there's a lot of misinformation about a lot of things. And when it comes to aging, what I see most often is the really, frankly, ageist belief that, to use an old saying that I can't stand, you can't teach an old dog new tricks. You know, people say that and it gets internalized and people just think, okay, well, I'm older. I'm stuck in my ways. I'm not going to be able to change how I do things. I'm not going to be able to learn something new. And that is the opposite of what's true. You continue to keep that ability to learn new things, to grow, to change, literally change your brain in addition to just being able to, you know, you can learn to play the piano age 60 or 70. You know, there's all these things that people might not have thought. Is it true that it might take longer? Sure. You know, your brain is changing as you get older. But number one, you can do things to minimize how much the brain changes as you age by doing these brain
你有没有在患者中遇到过关于大脑或衰老的常见神话？你知道的，有没有什么事是你特别想为今天听我们节目的听众澄清的？这可太多了。不幸的是，我们知道很多事情都有很多误导性的信息。而说到衰老，我最常见到的就是一种坦白讲非常带有年龄歧视的观念，借用一句我极其讨厌的老话：老狗学不会新把戏。你知道的，人们常说这句话，并且它已经深入人心，大家就会觉得，好吧，我老了，我这人就这样了，我没办法改变自己做事的方式，我没办法学新东西。而这与事实完全相反。你依然保留着学习新东西、成长、改变的能力，字面意义上改变你的大脑，不仅仅是说，你知道的，你可以在60岁或70岁时学弹钢琴。你知道的，有各种各样人们以前可能没想过的事情。它可能会花更长时间吗？当然。随着年龄增长，你的大脑确实在改变。但第一，你可以通过采取这些有益大脑健康的习惯，来尽量减少大脑随年龄增长而发生的变化。
healthy behaviors. You slow down the clock to some degree. And then even when the brain does change, you still retain so many abilities. So I think the biggest myth that I always wanted to spell is that aging equals inevitable, complete decline where you're not able to learn or do anything new. We can embrace that knowing that yes, something's changed but at each stage of life, there's so much that we can do. And there's power that we have to control to within some degree how we're aging and to continue to thrive and live well. I want to talk about memory for a minute. Most of us, as we get older, have experienced occasional moments where you can't come up with a word or a name. How can people decide that these are nothing to worry about and when they really are something
你在某种程度上减缓了时间的流逝。而且，即使大脑确实发生了改变，你依然保留了众多的能力。所以我认为我一直最想澄清的最大神话就是：衰老等于不可避免的、彻底的退化，让你无法学习或做任何新事情。我们可以接受这一事实，即有些事情确实变了，但在人生的每一个阶段，都有很多事是我们能够做到的。我们有力量在某种程度上控制自己的衰老方式，并继续茁壮成长、生活得很好。我想花一会儿时间谈谈记忆。我们大多数人在变老的过程中，都经历过偶尔想不起某个词或某个名字的时刻。人们该如何判断这些只是无需担心的小问题，还是真正需要去看医疗服务提供者的时刻？以及他们应该去看谁，以弄清楚这是否是严重的问题？这里有很多非常棒的问题。首先，我们要明白这些记忆卡顿不仅仅是由衰老引起的。我经常这样。有时是因为身为教授太忙了。我们所有人都会出于各种原因——压力、分心或其他事情——而出现记忆卡顿。
that they should get checked out by a health care provider? And who should they visit to find out whether it is something serious. Lots of great questions there. So I think first understanding that those memory slips are not just due to aging. I have them all the time. Sometimes it's being busy professor. All of us can for various reasons. Stress, distraction, other things have memory slips.
有时我们的记忆问题与抑郁、焦虑或其他可以治疗的疾病有关，它实际上并不是一种进行性退化，无论是由于衰老还是由于痴呆症引起的。因此，一个人出现记忆问题的原因有很多。了解这一点本身就是一个重要的观点：当你注意到自己的记忆发生变化时，不要想当然地认为这是某种会不断恶化的迹象。但也不要忽视它。我认为，如果你经常出现这种日常的记忆卡顿，比如记不起刚认识的人的名字，
Sometimes we have memory problems that are tied to depression or anxiety or something else that's treatable and it's not actually a progressive decline, either due to aging or due to dementia. So there's lots of reasons that a person can have in memory problems. And so knowing that is already an important point that when you notice that there's a change in your memory, don't assume that it's a sign of something that's going to be progressive. But don't ignore it either. I think if you're having this everyday memory slips, you can't remember the name of someone you just met.
弄丢了钥匙——我至少一周弄丢一次。所以诸如此类的事情只是日常的记忆卡顿，对大多数人来说，这根本不值得担忧。但是，当你开始注意到熟悉的人的名字你再也想不起来了，或者你长期掌握的信息变得更难提取出来时，那就是你可能会觉得：好吧，这开始变得不仅仅是任何人身上都可能发生的日常记忆闪失了，而且随着年龄增长，这种闪失确实会变得更常见。因此，当它开始干扰你的日常生活功能，当它开始涉及那些
You lost your keys, which I do at least once a week. So things like that are just everyday memory slips that are no, cause of concern or no cause for concern for most people. So, but when you start to notice that familiar people, you're not taking of their name anymore, or information that you've known for a long time is harder to kind of pull out, that's when you might say, okay, this is getting to be a bit more than just your everyday memory lapses that can happen with anyone and then do get more common as you get older. So when it starts to interfere with your functioning, when it starts to be about things that are
广为人知的信息，比如我刚才说的，熟悉的人的名字时，这可能就是一个更多的迹象，表明是时候去做个检查了。我也想说，如果它开始让你感到痛苦、让你担忧，并且干扰了你的思考，那就去检查一下，因为放下心来总比一直让自己越来越焦虑要好。而且，如果你一直焦虑，你就会开始出现更多记忆问题，因为焦虑会导致大脑发生变化。所以，拿不准的时候，还是去检查一下。但一定要明白，一定程度的记忆闪失是会发生的，如果真的发生了，也不必过度解读。当你决定是时候去做检查时，再次强调，大多数人首先会去找他们的初级保健医生。
like well-known information, like I said, like familiar people, that might be more of a sign that it's time to get checked out. I do also say that if it starts to become distressing, you're worried about it, it's interfering with your thinking, then get checked out because it's better to put your mind at ease than it is to kind of keep getting yourself more and more anxious. And then you will start to have more memory problems because you're anxious and anxiety can start to lead to brain changes. So when in doubt, still get checked out. but definitely understand that some degree of memory elapses happen and don't necessarily overthink that if that does happen. When you do decide that it's time to get checked out, so again, most people go first to their primary care doctor.
这样做没有什么不对。我提到过，在你希望每年一次的体检中，或者在你看初级保健医生的某些时候，这完全没问题。因为他们通常是帮你转诊给其他专家的门户。许多初级保健医生，特别是如果他们是老年病学家（专门研究衰老的人），可能会做一个简单的筛查来了解你的情况。这些筛查各有利弊。它们并不完美，但可以作为一种方法，初步看看是否有潜在的担忧原因，然后据此决定是否有必要进行转诊。但我想说的是，抛开作为神经心理学家的偏见不谈，神经心理学家在这方面扮演着重要角色，因为最终你被转诊去看的很可能就是神经心理学家。
There's nothing wrong with doing that. I mentioned in your annual, you know, hopefully physical that you get or some of the time that you see your primary care, that's perfectly fine. Because oftentimes they're the gateway to getting referrals to other people. many primary care people, particularly if they're a geriatrician, someone specializing in aging, might do a quick screener to see how you're doing. There's pros and cons to those screeners. They're not perfect, but they can be a way to see if there's initially some potential reason for concern and then can be used to then decide if a referral is necessary. But I would say aside from that, not to be biased because of a neuropsychologist, but a neurosychologist have an important role in this because ultimately who you get referred to will probably be a neuropsychologist.
而且你并不一定非得通过初级保健医生才能找到他们。我这里有大量的人是自己直接预约的，他们说：“我担心自己的记忆力，然后我查了亚特兰大地区的测试，找到了你。”你知道的，如果他们的保险能报销，或者如果他们想自费，诸如此类。他们不需要通过初级保健医生。所以你也可以寻找专家，理想情况下是神经心理学家，作为你的第一步，即使你不通过初级保健医生也行。我想你在书中说过，市面上真的没有什么适合做这个的家用测试，对吧？是的，没有。现在有很多试图开发家用测试的努力。说实话，我不相信它们。我不信任它们，因为我们需要从你身上获得太多精确的信息——需要有人看着你、看着你做测试、观察你如何完成某项任务，而不仅仅是看你最后的得分。所以当你进行神经心理学测试时，主试人员会观察你如何完成
And you don't always have to go through your primary care doctor for them. So I get plenty of self referrals from people who said, I was worrying about my memory and I looked up Atlanta testing and I found you and, you know, their insurance, if I can take them, then they never get to go or if they want to pay out of pocket, what have you. They don't have to go through primary care. So you can also seek out a specialist, ideally a neuropsychologist, as your first step, even if you don't go through primary care. And I think you said in your book that there really aren't any at-home tests that are going to be good for this, right? Yes. I don't. There's a lot of efforts trying to develop at-home tests. I'll be honest, I don't trust them. I don't trust them because there's just too many precise bits of information that we need from someone looking at you, watching you administering the test, seeing how you perform something, not just, what you do in the end. So when you do neuropsychological testing, the person is watching how you do
你正在做的事，因为这能提供更多信息。这可以帮助你做出一些微妙细微的决定，更不用说当你走进诊所时，你可以更好地将干扰降到最低，减少诸如偷看答案之类的情况发生。所以，我觉得看专家真的非常重要，而不要依赖那些家用测试。最后，总结一下，你接下来有什么计划？你现在在忙什么？有哪些重大问题？哦，有太多事情了。我正在做的大部分工作，其实可以分为两部分：一部分是研究层面，另一部分是走向社区。从研究层面来看，我的实验室非常感兴趣继续探讨关于脑健康的健康不平等问题。我非常感兴趣的一个重大领域是血管疾病与抑郁症的交叉点。当一个人患有多种血管疾病或危险因素时——可能是糖尿病、高血压、高胆固醇，这类医疗状况。当这些状况与抑郁症同时存在时，似乎就会产生双重打击，对大脑健康极其不利。当人们同时拥有这些时，我们称之为血管性抑郁。这不是DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）
what you're doing because that's more information. And it can help you with some of those nuanced decisions, not to mention that when you go into an office, you can really minimize distractions better, be less than the sheet, you know, look up an answer or whatever it is. So I just, I think it's really important to see a specialist and not to rely on those at-home tests. And finally, just to wrap up, What's next for you? What are you working on now? What are the big questions? Oh, so many things. So a big part of what I'm doing, so there's really two things. One is I go, research side and one is out in the community. So from the research side, my lab is really interested in continuing to ask some of these questions about health disparities when it comes to brain health. And a big area of interest for me is the intersection of vascular disease and depression. So when someone has multiple vascular conditions or, risk factors. So it could be diabetes, high blood pressure, high cholesterol, those types of medical conditions. When they have that along with depression, it seems to be this double whammy that is really bad for brain health, that when people have, we call it vascular depression. It's not a DSM,
官方诊断，但从研究的角度来看，这就是我们的称呼，因为这是一种似乎由慢性血管疾病引起的抑郁症。而当你拥有这种组合时，你会发现，在复杂的解决问题能力、抑制控制以及我们称之为执行功能的其他方面，会出现更多困难。我们发现，在管理日常生活方面会有更多困难，无论是完成工作要求，还是我刚才说的开车，这些日常功能性技能往往受到的影响更大。因此，我迷恋上了血管性抑郁这个概念，并希望了解我们该如何治疗它，
you know, official diagnosis, but that's from the research standpoint and that's what we call it, because it's depression that seems to be caused by chronic vascular conditions. And when you have that combination, what you see is that there's more difficulties with complex problem solving and inhibition and other what we call executive functions. We see that there is more difficulties with managing day-to-day life, whether that be completing, you know, job requirements or, again, driving those day-to-day functional skills tend to be more affected. And so I'm fascinated by this idea of vascular depression and understanding how we can treat
尤其是因为少数族裔群体患血管性抑郁的风险更高，因为慢性压力与血管疾病之间存在这种联系。所以我正试图弄清楚，有哪些干预措施、行为干预措施可以帮助降低患血管性抑郁的风险，以及我们是否有办法通过确保每个人都能获得他们所需的这些干预措施，来努力减少血管性抑郁方面的健康不平等。这就是我目前真正最大的热情所在。我也正试图将基于科学的、有益大脑健康的各种行为建议付诸实践，应用到我之前提到过我的公司Cerebral Fit中。所以我们真正在亚特兰大当地社区行动起来，努力为人们赋能，不仅赋予他们知识，还让他们有机会来到中心进行私人训练课程。我们有一个我称之为“禅室”的地方，供人们在非常美妙、放松的房间里缓解压力，那里有播放鸟鸣声的音箱、柔和的灯光，
it in particular because people from minorities are more at risk for vascular depression because there's that link between chronic stress and vascular disease. So I'm trying to understand what are the interventions, behavioral interventions that can help reduce the risk of developing vascular depression and are there ways that we can try to reduce health disparities
以及所有让人舒适的设施。你可以看营养师。你可以在一个地方获得认知评估。所以我认为，尝试开发在某种中心内整合这些服务的模式，对于希望在其他地方推广这种方法、帮助人们更好地获得有益大脑健康的行为可能会有所帮助。多森博士，听起来你在做一些非常棒的工作。改天我真得很想去参观一下你的禅室。随时欢迎。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 以及你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》以前的节目。
in vascular depression by making sure that everyone has the access they need to those interventions. So that's really my big passion right now. I'm also trying to sort of put into action all the suggestions based on science for brain healthy behaviors in my company's Cerebral Fit that I mentioned. So we're really in the community in Atlanta trying to empower people with knowledge, but also the ability to come into the center and have a personal training session. We have a what I call a Zen room for people to de-stress in a really wonderful relaxing room where there's speakers that have birdsong and there's light lighting
如果你喜欢我们听到的内容，请关注我们并留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以给我们发邮件：Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学对话》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。感谢收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。放松身心，把本周的杂货采购交给Ralph's送货服务吧。我们只挑选最新鲜的商品，然后核对您的清单并仔细挑选每一件。接着我们会把它们全部打包好，并在短短30分钟内送达，让您坚信这就是您订购的东西。
and just all the things that are comfortable. You can see a nutritionist. You can get a cognitive evaluation all in one place. So I think trying to develop models of integrating those services in one sort of center, I think could be helpful for hopefully expanding that type of approach in other places to help people have better access to brain healthy behavior. Dr. Dotson, sounds like you're doing some great work. I really want to visit your Zen room one of these days. You're welcome anytime. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
新鲜杂货，随您心意。使用Ralph's送货和自提服务。现在，您的第一笔送货或自提订单还可以节省20美元。Ralph's，为每个人保持新鲜。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you ordered.
本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Fresh groceries, your way. with Ralph's Delivery and Pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.